hey 42 here welcome to the weirdest city
in Alaska Whittier
but Whittier is the city that forgot how
to city because it is home to just 220
people and they all live in one building
yep
everyone lives in this monolithic tower
block of condos except this one guy who
thinks he's a badass and lives in a
mobile home right next door
his name is Paul by the way but Paul
aside this entire city's residents don't
just live in one building they go to
work school and do their shopping at to
the 14 story building is called Begich
tower and houses not only residential
condos for 220 people but everything
else you need to live the building
contains a police station two grocery
stores the city offices an indoor
playground a B&B
a laundromat a post office a health
clinic under school okay it doesn't have
a Hooters so not quite everything you
need to live but close it off oh did I
forget to mention there's also a church
in the basement God knows why it's in
the basement
residents of Whittier enjoy pure
isolation and live mostly after land
catching fish and other local wildlife
not only is Whittier encased on all
sides by towering mountains in a lake
but there is only one road to and from
the city which completely closes at
night the road is a single lane tunnel
through a mountain that only goes one
way at a time the direction of the road
changes at specific times throughout the
day on the plus side crime rates are low
since fees have to wait for the road to
change direction before making their
grand getaway which is awfully
inconvenient Whittier poses a strange
dichotomy with its extreme isolation and
low population you would think it's a
place for loners and extreme introvert
the kind of place where your weird
cousin Kevin might emigrate to and you
never see him again
but on the other hand you couldn't move
to a more interactive social environment
than Whittier you are literally living
underneath on top of and next to the
entire city's population you better hope
you get on with your neighbors because
they never bloody change residents are
known to regularly shuffle around the
building's many
hallways and rooms in their pajamas and
underwear bestowed with an unusual level
of comfort and familiarity with their
neighbors his school students get stuck
of their homework they simply knock on
the teachers door for help after all she
only lives down the hall but there's a
damn good reason these residents have
everything they need one building and
rarely set foot outdoors at least in the
winter because the entire place is
trying to kill you during the past
winter months Whittier is encased in a
meter of snow and being on the
waterfront in are you sure you want to
go outside Alaska it's constantly
blasted by 60 mile-per-hour winds and
because it is seriously though there's
bears out there Alaska there's a lots of
bears about this is the reason the
children's playground is indoors and
school kids have to pass through an
underground tunnel to go to school which
is in a building adjacent to Begich
towers connected only by this passageway
just try telling the people of Whittier
that winter is coming trust me they know
there's even an indoor vegetable garden
maintained by the school kits to provide
sustenance through the winter the
vegetables are grown using hydroponic
equipment donated by the police after
they seized it during a drug trade here
you go kids grow some herbs
it only takes a smart kid with access to
the Internet to realize they've got
everything they need to start a pop farm
so you've got to ask the question why do
these people do it apart from the
amazing views and the occasional rooftop
barbecue well most of these people
didn't move here out of choice they
simply found themselves living in
Whittier out of circumstance UC Whittier
was built during World War Two as a
military facility for the United States
Army they wanted the base somewhere
secluded and protected by the mountains
health congratulations you found it
Begich tower was built as barracks to
house the military the location was
still owned by the government until 1969
when it was given to the residents and
officially became the city the people
who live there now are simply the
remnants of the military base that once
was the descendants of soldiers and
workers who resided there
there isn't much demand for property
with you from outsiders today and the
population is slowly decreasing every
year it does draw a huge tourist trade
during the summer months though because
of its peculiarities and natural beauty
if you do intend to visit Whittier you
better do so fast before Begich towers
bits its final farewell much to the
dismay of its loyal 220 residents except
Paul he don't care he got his mobile
home thanks for watching there is a
Santa Claus University that teachers
professional Santa Claus skills like toy
knowledge poses and how to avoid
lawsuits a top-level Santa Clause can
make up to $100,000 a year but if you
take that Sun which are your mouth for a
second do you ever wonder how it ended
up on your plate
where did they grow the wheat to make
the bread what Pig did the ham come from
why did they put pickles in it they know
you hate pickles